mein name ist luca um meine lieben
zuschauer vor vielen jahren habe ich
dieses video hier auf meinem kanal
hochgeladen
das war ein video in dem ich euch
gezeigt habe wie man in minecraft in
unter fünf minuten in seiner ersten
diamanten findet und es war zudem auch
mein erstes richtiges youtube video und
ihr seht bereits im titel eingeblendet
dieses video stelle ich heute nach
beziehungsweise ich stellt sich richtig
eins zu eins nach sondern ich schaue mir
das video an stück für stück und
versuche die tipps die lokale gibt
selbst zu befolgen hey leute in diesem
video zeige ich euch einfach mal so hier
in einer zufällig generierten welt in
minecraft oder wie ersten diamanten
innerhalb von nur fünf minuten findet
ja
das war tatsächlich meine stimme früher
die müssen halt überlegen dass ich da
irgendwie 15 jahre alt war oder so aber
gut luca hat auf jeden fall hier
hingekriegt und
was muss ich als nächstes machen luca
dafür erstelle ich mir mal eben eine
neue welt ihr gesehen habt habe ich
keinen zieht ein gegeben das ist einfach
aus dem grund damit ihr nicht vorwerfen
könnte der hatten zählt genommen den hat
er vorher schon mal benutzt hat da
vorher schon geguckt oder diamanten sind
alles klar luca okay also stieg auf neue
welt erstellen nämlich nennen die welt
einfach mal erstes video und ich wähle
keinen zieht aus also klickt einfach auf
neue welt erstellen damit ihnen ich
denke wenn ihr da bin was ich als erstes
mache ist dass ich mir holzkohle okay
also luca hat sich als erstes holz
geholt das heißt ich geh auch hier als
erstes hin und bauen ein bisschen holz
ab die frage ist wie viel holz sich
eigentlich brauche dabei ist egal
welches das ist das kann diese hier sein
das kann auch dieses braune haut sein
das ist komplett egal
dann habe ich aber nicht gefragt ich
wollte wissen wie viel holz ich brauche
luca die könnt euch vier holz holen es
wäre aber besser wenn ihr euch fünf holz
holt das ist einfach sicherer wenn ihr
nachher noch mehr sex braucht okay also
drei holz habe ich schon jetzt das
vierte und vorne das fünfte also dann
gehen einfach mal den sicheren weg das
krasses auf minecraft sieht jetzt anders
aus ich meine ich dass hier an das ist
alles so wunderschön geworden und aber
gut hörbare weiter mit dem früheren
video ihr macht euch erstmal eine
workbench und zwölf stück hatten die
brauchen wir nachher also ab ins
inventar gehen und erst mal hier die
sachen zu den stämmen machen daraus
machen wir uns dann eine workbench die
haben wir hier und zwölf stärker meinte
luca also zwölf stücke haben jetzt auch
am start work bench setzt jetzt einfach
mal irgendwo hab ich jetzt einfach hier
ab und ich mache mir jetzt eine stein
schaufel und eine stein spitzhacke also
die workbench irgendwo abstellen die
stelle ich einfach mal hier an den see
und jetzt eine stein schaufel und einer
stein spitzhacke das heißt so zac und
wir haben hier einmal eine
und noch dass
wir auf einem guten weg und jetzt liegt
es an euch ihr könnt euch jetzt
irgendeinen port in eurer minecraft welt
suchen
die irgendeinen ort gar nicht mehr
suchen an dem ihr euch einfach in der
erde graben wollte ich könnte mich
natürlich jetzt auch schon hier in der
erde graben oder hier oder hier
oder auch hier
runter lukas vollidiot also gut dann
laufen wir hier jetzt mal einfach
irgendwo rum das ding ist wir sind halt
eigentlich sogar relativ schön bunt hier
sind überall so schöne bäumchen wir sind
überall so kleine seen here for jetzt
auch noch ein sehe ich mein halt
wirklich schaut euch das mal hier wissen
dass in minecraft ist so ein
wunderschönes spiel wichtig diese welt
einfach nicht danach aus dass hier die
montage system das sind daher in der
nähe keine berge sind also wenn ihr werk
gesät gerade durch am besten neben einem
berg in den boden dass es immer am
sichersten
ja berge sind jetzt nicht so unbedingt
vorhanden aber ich gehe erst mal von
diesem baum hier wieder runter das hier
vorne ist der höchste berg im ganzen
umkreis das heißt neben einem berg soll
man sich untergraben hier vorne ist es
eigentlich direkt neben dem berg so hier
sieht auch gut aus nebenan das werk ist
das schon bestimmt die verträge nicht
gerade mich einfach mal hier runter okay
also dann will ich jetzt meine holz
schaufel aus und grabe mich jetzt hier
einfach nach unten als bin ich bei
schwangeren gekommen das heißt ich euch
fortschritt oder hole ich noch ein paar
steine hier damit ich mir bessere
werkzeuge machen kann ok also wir sollen
uns jetzt erstmal noch ein paar
steinchen holen damit wir uns bessere
werkzeuge machen können einem das ding
ist wir haben ja auch direkt eisen
gefunden das ist auch gut weil damit
können wir nachher den diamanten abbauen
dafür jetzt mal einfach platt
geschrieben unter mir und macht mir die
gleichen sachen wie am anfang nur noch
mal entscheiden ich mache mir dann
erstmal hier eine stein spitzhacke und
dann mache ich mir noch eine schaufel
eben genau die packe ich hier vorne hin
und ich mache mir auch noch ebenen stein
schwert wenn ich hab schon die ganzen
sachen habe falls irgendwelche zombies
ankommen sollten und damit kann ich
jetzt sogar hier das eisen abbauen
gewünscht das machen wir natürlich
gerade nicht alles auf zeit wie ich das
damals gemacht habe habe ich wirklich
zeit gestoppt haben fünf minuten und
dann hatte ich sogar das glück dass ich
direkt diamanten gefunden habe sondern
wir bauen uns jetzt einfach ja wir
machen just for fun aber wie soll ich
den sommer weiter vorgehen ich habe mich
nämlich zwei blöcke immer unter weil
wenn ihr euch nur einen block runter
kraft wissen nicht was unter euch ist
deswegen kann es sein dass zwischendurch
mal einfach aber sie kommt ich habe
jetzt einfach mal so lang und habe sich
kohl oder eisen kohle haben wir direkt
hier gefunden das ist auch relativ schön
weil es gerade schon langsam dunkel wird
das heißt wir nehmen jetzt unsere sticks
packen die die kohle drauf können uns
die fackeln und können jetzt war er
ist natürlich sinnvoll wenn ich das
direkt auf die kohle setzen also das
natürlich sehr gut wenn ihr direkt pole
finde bis den ich unbedingt findet man
bestimmt auch noch unten aber ist
natürlich gut wenn jetzt findet nehmen
wir natürlich auch alles mit brauchen
wir später okay also der 15 jahre alte
luca meint auf jeden fall wir sollen
hier alles an kohle mitnehmen was wir
irgendwie haben das ding ist wir haben
hier wirklich unfassbar viel kohle
gerade gefundenen richtigen strang aber
vielleicht ist ja wirklich sinnvoll für
nach wegen die fackeln brauchen in der
höhle sind und so weiter und so fort ich
bin tatsächlich auf diese video idee
gekommen von wegen hey stellen wir ein
erstes video nach beziehungsweise bevor
ich mal deine eigene anleitung weil mir
moritz geschrieben hatte ich hatte mir
das video angeguckt und ich dachte das
sei so ein crank von dir gewesen aber
das war ja wirklich deine taktik stimme
von früher und er meinte dann so
wertvoll lustig wenn du das mal
nachstellen würde ist aber gut ich freue
mich jetzt weiter herunter oder was habe
ich in dem video damals gesagt wir haben
uns weiter unter und jetzt kommen ein
paar lex warum weiß ich nicht aber egal
ich lasse mich dadurch einfach mal nicht
beeindrucken okay also bei luca kam carl
xvi ich weiß noch ganz genau ich habe
das auf meinem kleinen alten kag apple
macbook whatever wie das auch hieß
gespielt das ging echt überhaupt nicht
klar aber wo ich freue mich jetzt auf
jeden fall mal weiter voran wie gesagt
ich hoffe einfach dass ich gleich auf
eine höhle schlosses beziehungsweise
aufweisen bzw direkt schon einen
diamanten finde das halte ich zwar für
unrealistisch staatlichen diamanten
meisters erst auf der höhe 15
beziehungsweise 16 kommen
aber
ich bin ja guten mutes alles guten mutes
dass wir irgendwie diamanten finden
werden habe ich natürlich gespannt ob
die taktik das muss man halt auch sagen
das video ist halt irgendwie 78 jahre
alt also ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das
ganze lief immer noch funktioniert als
ich traf mich einfach weiter in die
tiefe bis ich auf ein höhlensystem stoße
ja
ich hoffe auch dass ich so langsam auf
dem höhlensystem stoßen werden wenn ich
aufhöre 15 bzw 16 bin und auch keine
höhle gefunden habe werde ich mich
einfach in die seite graben aber
eigentlich stößt auf höher 15 oder 16
immer auf eine höhle also laut luca
stößt man auf höhe 15 oder 16 immer auf
eine höhle bisher sehe ich dafür noch
nicht so viel ich höre auch noch keine
zombies ich glaube das war in meinem
büro der fall dass da irgendwie auch
einen zombie geräusch waren duca daher
wusste hey hier ist eine höhle
und da haben doch schon den ersten sonic
at das heißt hier direkt nebenan muss
eine höhle sein und da haben wir auch
schon den lover see gefunden
er findet direkten lover sehen wir haben
gerade noch mal kohle gefunden genau
haben allerdings genug kohle und sind
jetzt auf höhe 16
und haben reisen aber keine diamanten
aber wie links hat in dem video weiter
ich verspreche euch nicht dass ihr
klappt was ich hier sage also das muss
nicht unbedingt klappen
[Musik]
dafür spreche auch nicht dazu ob das
musste ich über den klappen wasser auf
jeden fall super gemacht luca die schöne
aus der verantwortung geredet frühjahr
aber das hat das weiß nicht was damals
wirklich geklappt ich glaube ich weiß
ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie ich den
diamanten gefunden hatte aber das können
sie auch noch mal eben kurz anschauen
und da haben wir auch schon den ersten
jemanden gefunden das reich der keiner
stoppt jetzt einfach mal vier minuten
und 59 sekunden
wahnsinn
ja wir schauen ob ich ja oder diamanten
finden werde
aber ich bin allergisch gegen contest
das heißt nämlich in dem video auch dass
ich euch zeige wie man diamanten findet
nicht wie man sie ab
jetzt also um eine spitzhacke short
gegangen
[Musik]
ich höre ja aber auch ich höre hier
irgendwo lava ihr müsst jetzt bevor den
diamantenabbau könnt euch noch ein eisen
spitzhacke machen
und da sind auch gleich drei diamanten
reisen spitzhacke mache ich mir
aber du hast drei jammern und ich habe
sehr sucht
in den hier muss so ein lager seien und
das ist sind safe diamanten schweiz
[Musik]
das geräusch hörte sich so an als wäre
irgendwo eine höhle nebenan dreht
muss
was sagt luca noch im video also er hat
gesehen dass geht ziemlich schnell
jemanden zu finden mit diesem trick
ja wirklich das geht mir ja schnell mit
diesem trick diamanten zu finden
da oben der magath teil der meeting ende
hatte h
[Musik]
es wird
immer lauter
hahaha keiner mich geglaubt aber jetzt
zeige ich es allen helfern da das war
das ist ja 34 jahren mama ich habe den
lover see gefunden von dem luca walldorf
man ihm direkt finden wir der bad
tatsächlich direkt daneben wo ich mich
runter gegraben hat also ich hatte gar
nicht so viel pech habe ich hab ihnen
wenn ich nicht
ich
jetzt hier ist kein diamant
jetzt absolut hier ist hier ist kein
einziger kein einziger diamant
[Musik]
ich luke haben an dem ich das heute
wieder ist allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wie bereits gesagt hat
moritz auf die idee gebracht meinte
einfach ein luca ich habe letztens ein
erstes video vorgeschlagen bekommen
jetzt nicht lustig wenn das ganze mal
nachstellt ich habe es jetzt nicht
richtig nachgestellt von wegen ich
spreche jeden satz nach weil ich glaube
dass wir ein bisschen langweilig
geworden sondern ich wollte einfach ein
bisschen diese anleitung befolgen und
gucken ob es noch klappt und es hat
ewige bereits gesehen habt echt grandios
geklappt wenn ich das heute wieder
gefallen da würde ich mich auf jeden
fall sehr sehr toll war einen daumen
hoch von euch unter dem video hier
freunde schreibt mir auch mal gerne in
die kommentare
seit wann ihr abonnent zeit von einem
kanal was wird mich auch mal
interessieren gibt es wirklich leute die
mich nach diesem minecraft in unter fünf
minuten video abonniert haben geht jetzt
immer noch meine videos schauen dass wir
auf jeden fall mega witzig abonniert auf
jeden fall zu dem auch gern main kanal
falls noch kein teil der luxury seite
ist kostenlos und verpasst keine videos
mehr und der letzte satz gehört dir luca
von vor acht jahren ich hoffe ihr habt
euch das video angeschaut
[Musik]